et on commence avec avec top chef
onzième saison et ça cartonne eh ben ça
cartonne et c'est même arrivé un petit
peu devant tf1 à 3,2 millions
téléspectateurs un pic à 3 millions 8
une progression depuis deux cent mille
téléspectateurs en une semaine donc
c'est un succès pour le retour du
programme
alors c'est vrai moi j'étais pas fan des
émissions de cuisine et j'ai je suis
tombé dessus
eh ben on se fait au franchement cette
saison on se fait avoir commencé la
résidence sainte chiite à la rochelle
mais c'était large et le présent c'est
très sympa je les trouve vraiment
sympathique moi je n'aime pas la cuisine
a fait j'aime pas la faire j'aime la
manger mais je n'aime pas la faire
tendance à tout être vous n'étiez pas
grave et il est il un cuisinier chez lui
donc j'aimerais bien non mais c'est vrai
que cette année le le castilla et très
réussi ldc de justin qui est toujours
contente de tout rayon de soleil il ya
un vrai rayon de soleil
on vous a fait un petit un petit magnéto
regardez c'est vrai qu'elle rit tout le
temps et que allait vraiment envie de
bien cuisiner et surtout de beaucoup
rigolé t sans que là tout mon corps est
en ébullition j'ai la gauche je trouve
celui-ci
je me dis allez
que ça fasse faut que ça passe et gage
vous préviens la betterave à malte et
foncer je vais prendre votre place les
gardes cette gaffe
la petite mousse betteraves café ça
c'est surprenant et audacieux
c'est un espèce de tableau 1 qu'on a
devant les yeux et ça marche
franchement allez allez beaucoup sympa
c'est bizarre parce que vous n'avez pas
dû suivre des autres années parce que je
vous promets que ce qui est
extraordinaire avec cette émission c'est
que ça fait des années que c'est
toujours égale est toujours formidable
franchement les candidats sont toujours
top je vous le disais la semaine
dernière mais c'est vraiment ça on
s'attache à des gens qu'on va suivre
ensuite et ensuite qu'on voit ouvrir
leur restaurant et pourquoi pas ensuite
obtenir une étoile
franchement de cette émission pour moi
elle est extraordinaire vraiment on est
à la limite si vous avez d'autres de
regarder ses missions que tom je regarde
pas trop
j'avoue que si je regardais ce serait
pour philippe etchebest je trouve qu'il
y avait assez bien trempé assez drôle de
le voir elle a commenté je pense que
c'est pour ça aussi que ça marche alors
il a rien il ya un candidat c'est cette
année à qui il manque un oeil
c'est un petit peu le coup de coeur sur
les réseaux on a fait un petit à petit
les regards de garder ces malheureux
la semaine dernière on a découvert que
le jeune homme alors y avait eu un
accident tragique en cuisine
c'est un restaurant on m'a baptisé
évincé par terre un collègue me l'a
jetée en fait dans le seau et y avait de
l'eau mélangée avec de l'acide et je les
prie dans le visage
et depuis ce jour là voilà j'ai perdu la
vue entièrement d'un côté ça m'a donné
un caractère aussi que je n'avais pas
auparavant c'était un accident
mais ça m'a donné de la force selon elle
sera un vrai atout dans le fond m6 met
en lumière des gens qui sont passionnés
dont c'est la vocation donc la démarche
est sincère
ils viennent juste pas là pour se
montrer montrez leur tête à la
télévision et en plus de ça un top chef
c'est devenu comme la référence des
concours culinaires à la télévision
masterchef excès il ya dix ans ça a été
viré en plus de ça
l'émission a reconnu par ses pairs sire
que tous les grands chefs la reconnaisse
sont venus dans l'émission et ils disent
allez-y et aujourd'hui soyez toute une
nouvelle génération de chefs qui sort de
cette émission qui ont sont celui des
véritables stars bravo à l'émission pour
ça ah oui il ya même des candidats qui
ont été formés par des grands chefs
notamment qui était formé par guy savoy
qui est vrai un grand chef international
aujourd'hui donc c'est une vraie une
vraie valeur aujourd'hui auprès des
clients rêvent toc et des tic et tac du
média c'est vrai cette maison alors
c'est pour vous parler de guy savoy le
vin une confidence une fois j'étais dans
un avion et je vais le menu et ses oies
ou rien il ya un chef qui culmine chez
guy savoy sais pas mais ken à la mecque
est très bien alors
je partage je communie avec moi mon
téléspectateurs jeulin forme de ce que
je vis et quand j'ai vu ce nom que je ne
connaissais pas guy saboy je l'avais qui
savent on y voit excuse pour faire petit
de rigolade
paris re écouter et sortez c'est pas
grave chez vous une lacune de plus une
lacune merci voilà merci et non
justifiable vont pas tarder à montverdun
cela est juste car des gens du public
j'ai vu l'épisode a donc été diffusée il
y avait une épreuve que j'ai trouvé
formidable c'est le zéro déchet il avait
accusé un poisson il fallait le qg de la
tête aux pieds et je ne savais même pas
ce qui concerne la cus
on va bientôt terminer vos phrases quoi
mais en même temps je ne me rends compte
de l'énormité parce que qu il est un
poisson de la tête aux pieds foncia
quand même regarder voilà sa famille en
images réelles et c'est bon est-ce qu'on
a utilisé le poisson de la tête à la cud
sa messagerie avoue réfléchir jacques
ouest
les faucons les gouttes
[Musique]
lisieux bon ben l'audace à délimiter les
garçons rio des jeux vaches
la texture est hyper chelou ça croque
red door ya du sud et des yeux qu'est ce
que tu en penses
tout ça reste un grand bruit et quand
quelque chose domaine d'auriac
on ressent quand on élimine
éco-responsable d'ailleurs sur le
tournage de top chef toute la nourriture
qui n'est pas utilisé et rambert est
reversée à la croix rouge c'est plutôt
une bonne chose
les reverser père avait envoyé non parce
que remercier et cuisine de la tête aux
pieds et robert ce le poisson qu'ils
appellent des bouffées c'est vous dire
c'est un festival et c'est un savon miss
france de france pour vous malgré des
cas rares